بحذر شديد تكون حركتها في الحي خوفا من
القناص ف السلاح الحوثي ذاته الذي قتل
زوجها قنصل قبل اعوام يتهددها اليوم مع
اطفالها الى الحي في المنزل المدمر هذا هو
الذي لا يبرد سوى 20 مترا عن خط المواجهه
تعيش الام واطفالها حياه قاسيه تحت هدير
المدافع وعزيز الرصاص
لهذا المنطقه تمام
وحشرتهم في غرفه واحده الام في حاله الرعب
والفقر التي تعيشها الاسره تنسحب ايضا على
عشيره الاسر النازحه الى هذه المنازل
المدمره بعد انفرت من جحيم
الميليشيا‬/2016.com
هجرب البيت وبيتي كانت مقاول لها راحت عن
البيت الذي في الجروب بعدين نزحتنا
ما بدي باب من الخارج الازرق
محليه للتضعف اذا ماساه النازحين في تعز
ومعها تتفاقم معاناه في ظل الحصار ففي
احياء الزهره والكلب والخضره شرقي المدينه
تعيش اكثر من 170 اسره نازحه في خط تماسي
الحرب دون ان تحصل على ابسط مقومات العيش
كالماء والغداء لاحد اذا يسكن هذه المنازل
المدره عند خطوط تماسي الحرب شرقي مدينه
تعز سوى الاسر الناجحه التي اضطرت الى ذلك
بعد ان عجزت من الحصول على مساكن امنه فهم
يعيشون داخل هذه المنازل دائما تساقط
القذائف على رؤوسهم هل سعيد لقناتيه
العربيه والحدث من حي الخضراء شرقيه مدينه
تعز